MONTHS EARLIER.
FOX NEWS IS CONTINUING EFFORTS
TO TRY TO GET BACK INTO THE
COUNTRY TO PROVIDE LIVE COVERAGE
INSIDE VENEZUELA SOON.
THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT IS
UNVEILING NEW TECHNOLOGY
DESIGNED TO REMOVE EXTREMIST
MATERIAL FROM THE INTERNET.
THIS SOFTWARE AIMS TO STOP THE
OBJECTIONABLE CONTENT BEFORE IT
GOES ONLINE.
HERE IN THE U.S., THERE IS
CONCERN THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
LOSING THE BATTLE TO KEEP
TERRORISM OFF THE WEB.
HERE IS CORRESPONDENT JULIAN
TURNER.
>> AS.
MEDICS RUSHED TO TREAT VICTIMS
IN NEW YORK CITY'S HALLOWEEN
TEAM OR EXPERTS WERE QUICK TO
WARN LAWMAKERS ABOUT ISIS
CONNECTIONS IN REAL TIME AS THE
ATTACK WAS UNFOLDING.
>> THERE HAS BEEN AN EXPLOSION
THAT SUGGESTS THERE MAY BE A
LINK BUT JUST UNFOLDED.
>> NOW RISING CONCERN ABOUT AN
UPTICK IN JIHADIST ACTIVITY,
WARNING THAT AL QAEDA SPREADING
PROPAGANDA MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
ACCELERATING.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
FBI IS INCREASINGLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT WE HAVE SEEN WHAT
THEY ARE CALLING THE TIME
CONDENSED, THE TIME THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE BECOMING EXPOSED
TO THE CONTENT AND THE TIME IT
TAKES THEM TO LAUNCH AND CARRY
OUT THE ATTACK.
>> AMERICANS AND EUROPEAN
LAWMAKERS NOW DEMAND ACTION FROM
SOCIAL MEDIA SAYING IT IS TIME
TO STEP UP AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR CONTENT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR CONTEN
CONTENT.
BUT IN HEARINGS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE ATLANTIC, THESE HIGH-TECH
GIANTS INSIST THEY ARE DOING ALL
THEY CAN TO CURTAIL JIHADIST
ACTIVITY, EMPHASIZING NEW
PROGRAMS AND TECHNOLOGIES MEANT
TO STYMIE TERRORIST MESSAGING
AND RECRUITMENT.
>> WE ARE NOW AT 98% OF THE
CONTENT WE HAVE REMOVED HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY OUR ALGORITHM.
THAT NUMBER VARIES FROM POLICY
TO POLICY DEPENDING ON HOW
EFFECTIVE AND PRECISE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS ON PARTICULAR
ISSUES.
>> ONE OH OFFICIAL IN BOTH
ADMINISTRATIONS CAUTIONS THAT
GOVERNMENT AND SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES HAVE A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> THEY HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO POLICE THEIR OWN NETWORK, BUT
ME AND     WE AND THE GOVERNMENT
ME AND     WE AND THE GOVERNMENC
ME AND     WE AND THE GOVERNMENN
ME AND     WE AND THE GOVERNMEND
ME AND     WE AND THE GOVERNMENO
A BETTER JOB OF PROVIDING
INFORMATION SO THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AND THEY
KNOW THE SIGNS AND INDICATORS
ARE.
>> WITH THE U.S. DECIMATING
ISIS'S CALIPHATE, ALL EYES ARE